IS THAT WHAT HE'S GOING TO PUSH
FOR TOMORROW NIGHT WHEN HE
ADDRESSES THE NATION?
JOINING ME NOW,
KELLYANNE CONWAY.
THERE IS SOME REPUBLICANS WHO
ARE WORRYING THAT BY DECLARING A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY, THE
PRESIDENT COULD THEN OPEN
HIMSELF UP FOR MONTHS AND YEARS
OF LEGAL DISPUTES AND GET IT ALL
MOCKED UP.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
ADDRESS THE NATION TOMORROW.
HE'S GOING TO LAY OUT THE FACTS
AND FIGURES OF WHAT HE CONSIDERS
TO BE A HUMANITARIAN AND
SECURITY CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
>> Laura: IS HE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE NATIONAL EMERGENCY
ASPECT?
>> HE SAID HE'S CONSIDERING IT.
HE'S NEVER COMMITTED TO IT.
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S IS
RESEARCHING IT.
THERE ARE PROBABLY SOME PEOPLE
WHO WANT HIM TO DECLARE IT SO
CONGRESS -- CONGRESS AND THE
COURTS HAVE FAILED TO DO THEIR
JOB.
THEY'VE GIVEN US THIS CRISIS.
WHEN PEOPLE DENY THE USE OF THE
ROAD CRISIS OF THE BORDER, IT'S
SAD TO ME BECAUSE WHAT IS NOT A
CRISIS IS NOT AN DRUGS, THE
COCAINE AND HEROIN COMING OVER
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
90% OF THE HEROIN, GOVERNMENT
STATISTICS SAY, COME OVER THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
DHS SAYS THERE IS A 73% INCREASE
IN FENTANYL COMING OVER THE
BORDER.
BORDER PATROL CAPTURED ENOUGH
FENTANYL TO HAVE KILLED EVERY
MAN, WOMAN, AND CHILD IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> Laura: I AM ALL FOR THE
WALL.
>> THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IS
VERY WELL.
IT BREAKS MY HEART.
I'M CONSTANTLY BEING ASKED.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT THE CHILDREN,
YOU WOULD AGREE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT TAKE THIS PERILOUS TRACK IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
WE HAVE THIS MASSIVE INCREASE IN
FAMILY UNITS.
>> Laura: WE TALKED ABOUT IN
THE ANGLE.
>> IF YOU REALLY CARE, AS THE
DEMOCRATS AND MANY NEWS MEDIA
CLAIM THEY DO, YOU WOULD DETER
THEM FROM TAKING THIS PEERLESS
TRACK IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THE INCREASE OF PEOPLE COMING.
>> Laura: IT REQUIRES A
LEGISLATIVE FIX.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN GOING ON
THIS FOR YEARS.
CONGRESS -- HOW DO YOU GET THOM
TILLIS, CORY GARDNER, SUSAN
COLLINS.
THEY WERE GREAT ON SUPPORTING
THE PRESIDENT ON KAVANAUGH.
THEY WERE GREAT ON THAT BUT THEY
ARE GETTING ANTSY ABOUT THE
SHUTDOWN.
I'M HEARING ALL THE LITTLE --
I'M GETTING CALLS FROM PEOPLE.
THE SHUTDOWN.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY SHUT
DOWN TO THE WILL OF THE PEOPLE
ON THIS ISSUE.
WHEN YOU ARE DOING THE POLLING
BUSINESS A FEW YEARS AGO, YOU
DEMONSTRATED THAT.
IT'S NOT CHANGED.
>> 2014.
>> Laura: I STILL CITE THAT
POLL.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
EVER DONE.
LEVEL OF IMMIGRATION, PEOPLE
WANTED TO STAY THE SAME OR GO
DOWN.
>> IN 2014, PRESIDENT OBAMA HAD
THE CHILDREN OF THE BORDER
CRISIS.
SECRETARY JEH JOHNSON AT
HOMELAND SECURITY THEN WROTE
MEMOS THAT I BROUGHT WITH ME
TONIGHT.
FASCINATING READS.
WE WERE DOING THE POLLING IN THE
MIDST OF THAT AND EVEN THEN,
AMERICANS AGREE THEY WANT THESE
CHILDREN BY LARGE BE RETURNED
SAFELY TO THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
MEXICO HAS OFFERED ASYLUM AND
VISAS, SAFE PASSAGE TO THESE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE FAMILY UNITS
AND UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN WERE
COMING HERE.
THEY CAN HAVE THEIR CLAIMS OF
YOUR PROCESS WHILE THEY ARE IN
MEXICO.
>> Laura: I WANT TO GET YOUR
REACTION, KELLYANNE, TO A DEBATE
OVER HOW MANY TERRORISTS ARE
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS THROWN
AROUND A NUMBER OF ABOUT 4,000
BUT U.S. CUSTOMS AND BORDER
PROTECTION SAYS THEY ENCOUNTERED
SIX IMMIGRANTS WITH TERROR TIES
ON THE BORDER WITH MEXICO IN THE
FIRST HALF OF THE FISCAL YEAR
2018.
WE DON'T KNOW ABOUT THE
SECOND HALF.
I PERSONALLY THINK ONE TERRORIST
IS A PROBLEM.
WE KNOW IT ONE TERRORIST CAN DO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
IN PARIS.
A FEW IN EACH PLANE ON 9/11.
YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO, THEY TAKE
THAT AND SAY YOU'RE TRYING
TO SCARE THE PEOPLE AND
IT'S A MUCH SMALLER THREAT THEN
YOU DESCRIBE.
DOESN'T THAT HURT THEIR
CREDIBILITY OF THE WHITE HOUSE
WHEN WE DON'T GET THE BASIC
FACTS RIGHT IN SOMEONE'S NOT
DOING THEIR HOMEWORK ON THE WAY
THEY DESCRIBE IT.
>> THIS PRESENTATION PUT FORTH
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY, SECRETARY NIELSEN HAS
NOW BRIEFED THE DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES WHO WERE IN THE
MEETING THIS AFTERNOON TODAY.
I SAT THERE SHE BRIEFED 50
REPORTERS WITH THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
SHE ALSO DID IT WITH SOME OTHER
JOURNALISTS.
I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE ON PAGE THREE, I BELIEVE
IT'S ON THE WEBSITE AS WELL,
THIS IS A 3755 NUMBER DOES NOT
REFER TO GIVE LOVE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
"KNOWN OR SUSPECTED TERRORIST
PREVENTED FROM ENTERING OR
TRAVELING THE U.S. BY DHS."
THAT INCLUDES SOME INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORTS.
>> Laura: OVERWHELMINGLY AT
THE AIRPORTS.
>> THE OTHER STATISTICS WERE
ABOUT THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IT GOT UNFORTUNATE CONFUSED.
THE APPREHENSIONS OF THE BORDER
OF GANG MEMBERS, HAVE KNOWN
CRIMINALS, THESE ARE ALL --
AGAIN, THE MEDIA HAS THIS
PRESENTATION.
THEY WANT TO BE HONEST.
>> Laura: THEY ARE CHERRY
PICKING.
THEY ARE CHERRY PICKING.
THEY DO IT WITH SUPREME COURT
NOMINEES.
THEY DO TO ALL OF US.
WE ALL KIND OF MAKE MISTAKES, WE
ARE TALKING ALL DAY LONG.
>> EVERYBODY MAKES MISTAKES, ALL
OF US.
THE FACT IS IT'S CORRECTED HERE.
ANYBODY WHO TURNS A BLIND EYE TO
THE ACTUAL NUMBERS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, THE INCREASE IN
DRUGS, WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
YOUR CHILDREN HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES NOT BEING SUBJECT
TO ALL THESE DRUGS.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN.
>> Laura: IS IT GOING TO BE
PERSONALIZED TOMORROW NIGHT?
ARE WE GOING TO HEAR ABOUT THE
PEOPLE.
NUMBERS, PEOPLE'S EYES GLAZE
OVER.
400,000 WILL CROSS THE BORDER.
>> IN THE PRIVATE MEANINGS, THE
PRESIDENT HAS MADE VERY MANY
PERSONAL APPEALS.
>> Laura: I HOPE THAT'S
TOMORROW NIGHT TOO.
>> MAKING IT CLEAR, PLEASE DON'T
TAKE YOUR CHILDREN, VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS INCREASINGLY SHOWING
UP AT THE BORDER.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE
NASTINESS OF THE RHETORIC?
YOU AND I HAVE FELT IT
PERSONALLY.
BIG DEAL.
WE ARE BIG GIRLS.
WE HAVE DEALT WITH IT FOR YEARS.
THAT, FROM SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS
WHO ARE REVEALING THEMSELVES DAY
AFTER DAY AFTER DAY, THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN GOES ON.
RASHIDA TLAIB, NEWLY ELECTED
CONGRESSMAN SAID THIS ABOUT HER
PREVIOUS COMMENTS, PROFANE,
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I STAND BY IMPEACHING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
I RAN ON THAT.
I AM PASSIONATE AND I GREW UP IN
AN INCREDIBLY BEAUTIFUL URBAN
COMMUNITY, THE CITY OF DETROIT,
BORN AND RAISED.
WE SAY COLORFUL THINGS IN
INTERESTING WAYS.
I TELL YOU THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS MY FOCUS.
THE RESIDENTS BACK HOME ARE MY
FOCUS.
>> I DON'T KNOW -- THEY ARE ALL
PHYSIOLOGICALLY INCAPABLE OF
BEGINNING OR ENDING A SENTENCE
WITHOUT SAYING DONALD TRUMP
SEVEN TIMES AND SHE PROVED IT.
LET'S GO BACK TO HER ORIGINAL
PROFANE COMMENT.
SHE SAID SHE HAD BEEN TALKING TO
HER SON ABOUT BECOMING A
CONGRESSWOMAN AND THEN SHE MADE
IT -- SHE WAS BRUSHED BACK
PRETTY SEVERELY AND SWIFTLY BY
CONGRESSMAN NADLER, CERTAINLY BY
SENATOR JOE MANCHIN.
WITH RESPECT TO HER COMMENTS,
THAT WE DON'T SPEAK THAT WAY.
IT'S NOT NECESSARY.
JUST THIS WEEKEND, YOU SAW THE
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP IN THE
HOUSE HOLDING WAY BACK ON THIS
NOTION OF IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE WORRIED, I THINK THE
FRESHMAN MEMBERS COMING IN HERE
SAYING I THOUGHT THAT'S WHY WERE
HERE.
YOU'RE HERE TO REPRESENT THE
CONSTITUENTS THAT ELECTED YOU
AND YOUR HERE TO REPRESENT THEIR
INTERESTS.
THIS PRESIDENT HAS KEPT US SAFE
AND SECURE AND MORE PROSPEROUS.
IF THEY WANT TO GET IN THE WAY
OF THAT, THEN THEY ARE --
>> Laura: HE'S NOT GOING TO
RELENT ON THE SHUTDOWN.
>> HE'S NOT GOING TO RELENT ON
BORDER SECURITY.
>> Laura: WALL OR BORDER
SECURITY.
>> HE HAS HAD ITS ALL THE SAME.
MEANING THAT IT WILL BE MADE OF
U.S. STEEL, AMERICAN STEEL.
>> Laura: HE HAS COMPROMISED.
THEY ARE NOT TO COMPROMISE.
>> THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
MANY PEOPLE SAY YOU SHOULD SEE
THROUGH IT.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL SO YOU
NEED TO SEE THROUGH IT.
>> Laura: I DON'T GET IT.
>> THEY NEED TO SEE WHAT'S ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
THE PRESIDENT IS LISTENING TO
THEM.